[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: This is
primarily a question and
answer show so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
VIC FRYZEL: Hello, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Vic Fryzel, and this
is Nicolas Garnier.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Hello.
VIC FRYZEL: Today we're going to
be talking about the Google
Drive SDK again, specifically
around how to get started
using Java and the Drive SDK.
So what we're going to do today
is walk through the Java
Quickstart example that we
provide in the Drive SDK
documentation.
And we're going to
show that on the
screen here in a minute.
Essentially, what the
example does is
upload a file to Drive.
It's a basic command-line
example that you can run by
downloading the Java client
library, setting your client
ID in secret, and then
just running it.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yep,
that's right.
VIC FRYZEL: So we're going to
walk through how to do that.
So first, let's take a look
at the documentation.
Can you pull this up here?
So here's the Drive SDK
homepage, but we need to pull
up the Java Quickstart
example.
So we're going to click Get
Started Now, and then this is
going to take us to the
Quickstart page.
We're having a bit of network
latency at the moment.
OK, so here we go.
This is going to walk you
through in about five minutes
how to set up the Java
Quickstart example.
So you can see here that Java's
highlighted already.
But all of the different
languages have to walk through
these first steps.
So do you just want to
talk about these?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, I'll
do the first steps, Vic.
So the very first step is to
create an API project in the
Google API console.
I'll show that in a minute.
Then basically enable the Drive
API and create your
OAuth 2 credentials.
That will allow you to basically
tell us who you are
as a developer, register your
application, and where we'll
give you a quota, and you'll
be able to use OAuth 2
basically in your application.
So the first step you need to
do here is the Google APIs
console, which you can access
through the URL code
google.com/api/console.
You need to create
a new project.
So you go into the little
menu on the top
here and click Create.
If you have no project, you'll
have one big button in the
center of the screen.
It will say Create a Project.
You can give it any name.
I'm just going to
leave that name.
The project is getting
created.
Here you go.
And the second step is to enable
the drive API because
the API we're going to use with
the OAuth 2 credentials
that we are going to create.
If you want to use any other
APIs in your code later on,
just come here, enable the other
APIs, and your OAuth 2
credentials will work for
these APIs as well.
So the first step is to go to
API access here and create an
OAuth 2 client ID.
So you have to give another,
again, your product name.
We're going to go with--
I don't know--
I like testproject.
Then, for this particular
sample, you need to select
Install application because it's
a command-line tool, so
it's not a web application.
It basically means that the
application doesn't really
have access directly to a
browser and cannot do the
OAuth 2 full server-side flow
where the application directs
you to a website and you
get redirected back.
So you have to choose Install
Application here.
OK, create a client
ID, and that's it.
We got our client
ID in secret.
So let's go back to the steps
you want to follow up.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, so the next
thing Nicolas is going to do
is download the Google Drive
Java client library.
So this is essentially a Java
library that allows you to
easily interact with
Google APIs.
So this is something
we provide as
an open source project.
I think Nicolas already has
it downloaded here.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, it's
about, I think, 11 megabytes.
So just to avoid waiting for the
download, I have the zip
file here, which I
just unzipped.
VIC FRYZEL: Yep.
So it contains just
a bunch of jars.
And what we're going to do is
add these jars to our class
path and then download the
actual source code that we're
going to run, which is just
a short little hop here.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So this right
here that I have highlighted
is the contents of Google Drive
classes that you'll need
to use to access Google Drive.
That makes it easy for you to
access Google Drive API.
It contains also the Libs
folder, which contains
basically our dependencies that
you also need to add in
the class path.
VIC FRYZEL: OK, so
lets add these.
So if you're using an IDE like
Eclipse or IntelliJ, this is
going to be a little
bit different.
You should know how to add
JARs to your class path.
If you don't though, we
actually link in the
documentation on how to do it
for each individual IDE.
So here you have the command
all set to run to compile a
sample, except one step
we didn't show is just
downloading the source code,
like copying and pasting it
from the documentation.
So just show where that
is really quick in the
documentation.
NICOLAS GARNIER: That
is-- set of sample.
VIC FRYZEL: If we just
scroll down here.
So this is actually
the source code.
Nicolas--
NICOLAS GARNIER: Well, I'm going
to actually create the
file right now using
VI, using VIM.
So this is the sample
for the project.
It's very simple.
It's only one class.
Inside the template, you're
going to have to enter the
client ID and the
client secret.
And then we'll also have to
create an example file, which
is going to be called
document.text, which is the
file that's going to be uploaded
to Google Drive using
that sample using
the Java code.
So let me just create
that tile.
Just trying to get
the name right.
All right, that's it.
VIC FRYZEL: So like you
mentioned before, the only
thing we have to do to the
source code now is paste in
our client ID and secret.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, I'm also
going to create, very
quickly here, the example file,
which is going to be
documents.text.
And what do you want
in there, Vic?
VIC FRYZEL: Hello World.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Hello
World, for a change.
All right, that's it.
VIC FRYZEL: So let's
just go back.
So here, you can see that we
have two lines where we place
our client ID and our
client secret.
These are in the API console
project that we just created.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So this
is the client ID?
VIC FRYZEL: Mm-hm.
NICOLAS GARNIER: And now
the client secret.
And then I save and quit.
VIC FRYZEL: Yep.
OK, and then let's just go back
to the previous command
where we added all of the
JARs to the class.
NICOLAS GARNIER: All right, then
what we're going to show
now is basically simply
compiling that source file
that we just created
and then running it
in the command line.
So I had the commands ready.
As you can see, we're setting
the class pass correctly,
including the current folder,
which contains the Google API
server's drive v2, rev5,
172-bit, a JAR, which
contains, as I said, the drive
business subjects, basically,
and the Libs folder, which
contains all our dependencies.
VIC FRYZEL: Yep.
NICOLAS GARNIER: All right.
VIC FRYZEL: So that worked?
No errors?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Perfect,
no errors.
VIC FRYZEL: Now we just
have to run it.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Now
let's just run it.
Here is the Java command
to run it.
All right.
So now we have to go through the
out-of-band OAuth 2 flow,
which basically--
here's basically how it works.
We are asking the user to go to
that particular URL, which
we printed on the screen
here, which we're
going to do right now.
Then the user is going to say if
he wants to allow access to
his Google Drive data to the
test project or if he doesn't
actually want to allow access.
And here is how the out-of-band
OAuth2 works is,
we give you the OAuth code here
in the browser, and you
have to copy paste that
into the application.
The application is using the
code going through the OAuth
protocol, exchanging the code
for tokens, then uploading the
file, and here you go.
And now we have the file ID.
The file has been uploaded
to Google Drive.
So I'm going to go to my
drive and search for--
let's say, a text file.
Maybe there's a bit
of a delay.
What was the name?
Document--
VIC FRYZEL: Document.txt.
NICOLAS GARNIER: --.txt.
We're facing a bit of trouble.
VIC FRYZEL: This is unusual.
NICOLAS GARNIER: This
is unusual.
Usually the file shows up right
away in your drive.
So maybe the network
agency that we're
having are causing this.
VIC FRYZEL: So refresh.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Lets just
do a full refresh.
As you can see we're having
a very slow connection.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
NICOLAS GARNIER: All right,
it's not there.
VIC FRYZEL: You lied.
NICOLAS GARNIER: I lied.
I totally lied.
If you want--
VIC FRYZEL: Did you use
the right account?
NICOLAS GARNIER: I did.
There's only one account.
So if you want, I'm going
to get the file idea.
And do you want me to use the
OAuth 2 Playground maybe to
show the actual file has
been uploaded to Drive?
We could.
VIC FRYZEL: Sure.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah?
So if you guys know the
OAuth 2 Playground--
sorry.
Playground is a tool that allows
you to play around with
APIs that use the OAuth
2 protocol.
It lets you go through
your protocol.
This is the OAuth 2
web server flow.
We're just enabling the
Playground to access the
Google Drive API for us on my
accounts, exchanging the code
for tokens.
And here is a little convenient
tool to allow you
to select the right
REST operation.
And we want to actually
get the file that
we've uploaded to Drive.
We can see the file
has been uploaded.
VIC FRYZEL: Yes, it's
definitely there.
The title is My Document,
though.
VIC FRYZEL: Oh, whoops.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Which is
probably a little issue in our
Java sample, which we'll
fix later on.
VIC FRYZEL: Actually, for what
it's worth, I think all of the
samples are called
My Document.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Oh, OK.
VIC FRYZEL: So maybe our search
was just incorrect the
entire time.
NICOLAS GARNIER: All right.
VIC FRYZEL: Whoops.
NICOLAS GARNIER: We can see the
My Document file has been
uploaded here.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, good
job, Nicolas
NICOLAS GARNIER:
Yeah, awesome.
This totally worked exactly
as expected.
So I'm just going to
open the file.
You can see the ID here
on the URL, which is
with the correct ID.
VIC FRYZEL: Next time we'll
have better network
connection.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yes.
VIC FRYZEL: Oh, there we go.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Now
we can see the
Hello World file, awesome.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
Success.
NICOLAS GARNIER:
Success, boom.
VIC FRYZEL: Massive
excitement.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yes.
VIC FRYZEL: So now we can go
through the source code a
little bit and talk
through, line by
line, what we're doing.
NICOLAS GARNIER: OK.
VIC FRYZEL: So, pretty much
what we start off doing is
setting up authorization.
This is something that you
have to do in pretty much
every interaction you have
with the Drive SDK.
So authorization varies
language by language.
But here, we're creating the
Google authorization code flow
and just giving it
a few parameters.
Most of these parameters you
don't really ever have to
modify except for the client
ID and client secret.
And that's pointed out
pretty directly at
the top of file there.
And if you were writing a web
application, you would also
have to modify the
redirect URI.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, you
wouldn't really use this
out-of-bound flow.
If you were billing a web app,
you would actually use
probably the web service flow or
the client side flow, which
is a flow for JavaScript
application, which includes,
as I've just shown, using
the OAuth2 Playground.
Your app would handle the
redirect back and forth to the
grant page, which makes it way
better for users than having
to copy paste this URL.
VIC FRYZEL: Yep.
So once we set up the
authorization flow, we
actually initialize it and then
run a request to Google
to get an authorization URL,
which the user then
has to browse to.
And once they browse to that,
that's when they get the
authorization code and copy
and paste that back to us.
So you can see here in the next
five lines that we're
pretty much just--
NICOLAS GARNIER: This
is all done here.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, getting the
URL, telling the user to
browse to it, and then clicking
the code back.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, so when
the user copy/pastes that code
back, we take it, and we
exchange it for tokens, so an
access token and a
refresh token.
And we get this credential
object here on that line,
which contains actually the
access token and the refresh
token that we got back
from Google.
And then you can use that to
initialize your Drive service.
That's this line.
And then, very simply,
it's a few lines.
You create the file, which
actually correctly has the
title My Document.
I'm so sorry.
I really thought we were
giving the name
of the actual file.
So my search was wrong, but the
sample worked as expected.
And then we simply also read
the actual file itself, the
content of the actual file,
and then insert the file.
It's like this one
command line.
Insert the file to Google Drive,
giving it the metadata
that we've created here
and the file content.
VIC FRYZEL: Yep.
OK, so now that we've walked
through that, we can talk
about other ways that you might
be able to extend this
to be more of a realistic
application.
So there are few things that,
if you were running a real
command-line application
using the Drive SDK,
that you should do.
And not even just a command-line
application, but
rather a desktop application.
The out-of-band flow is what you
would use in order to do
authorization.
But having the user copy and
paste a link into their
browser frankly is not a very
good user experience, right?
And having them copy and paste
the code back to your
application just doesn't make
any sense to a user.
So what you should do is fire
up a web server locally.
And then the redirect URI for
an out-of-band OAuth flow
redirects the user back
to local host.
That's a valid redirect URI.
So here you would redirect the
user back to local host and
spawn up a web server on their
computer and then receive the
authorization code
in the request.
Once your web server receives
that, you would shut the web
server down, and now you have
the code that's needed.
So again, those steps are, one,
start up a web server.
Two, open up the user's browser
for them and send them
straight to that link.
When they click Allow Access,
your web server will receive
the request.
And then close the browser,
close the web server.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Or you could
display a message to the user
like, hey, switch back
to the application.
we've got the code now.
You can shut off your browser
and go back to the--
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, there are
probably even fancy ways to
detect that you've received the
grant and then close the
browser for the user
and just come
straight back into context.
So that's what you would do in
a more real-world context.
We don't do that here because
this is a very
quick-start-oriented sample.
Also, if you were writing a real
Drive integration on a
desktop application, you
would do much more
than upload, right?
You would probably at least
download files.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, list
files, download content,
everything you can do through
the Drive API, change the
sharing of files, search
for files.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, so we list
complete Java samples on how
to do every single thing in
the API in the reference
documentation, which is linked
to in the left half of our
documentation.
NICOLAS GARNIER: If you're
building also a web
application and want to use the
server side flow, we have
a really good sample on our
authorization documentation
page online.
So invite you to go
check it out.
VIC FRYZEL: We call that
sample Dr.Edit.
It's our flagship web
application sample.
And we have that in every
language as well.
So I think that's
pretty much it.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yep.
VIC FRYZEL: Anything else
you'd like to add?
NICOLAS GARNIER: I think
that's it as well.
VIC FRYZEL: All right.
Well, thank you so
much for joining.
We're super glad to have you.
I'm Vic Fryzel, and this
is Nicolas Garnier.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Thank
you, everyone.
VIC FRYZEL: And we'll
see you next time.
Bye.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]